[Music]
right welcome to mexico i'm going to
start off the day with an amazing
breakfast staple here
chili keta's done with some beautiful
tortilla chips left over molly and some
fried egg this is breakfast like no
other
so you see me cook many breakfast dishes
before from
beef scrambled eggs the poached eggs the
fried eggs but this is on a different
level
and let me tell you i'm about to educate
aron sanchez
and show him some true oaxacan style
mexican cuisine
and between you and i i don't think
you've even been to oaxaca
so how can a six foot two 222 pound
solid bag of muscle be in
oaxaca before you no fast track now
buddy
sit down watch and learn and
get some tissues because you're going to
need them because you'll be crying your
eyes out
why didn't you learn the authenticity of
proper oaxacan cuisine
breakfast we have some pork fat
okay that is rendered down from the pork
shoulder
look at it beautiful put a little touch
of oil in there
to break it up the smell inside there is
amazing
get your eggs always tap on a flat
surface
open up and crack in there beautiful
again flat surface
and then we go now that yolk is broken
but we do not waste anything
again in from there season those eggs
okay
beautifully done cook and season the
eggs
as they cook they need seasoning a
little bit of help start
on a high heat okay
from there take a little bit
of chili i'm just gonna go down through
the ends
i'm gonna keep the seeds in okay and
then just literally
slice nice and fine okay lift that up
and just sprinkle that on top of the
eggs
beautifully let that nicely
cook through the nice thing about a
rustic breakfast here in oaxaca
is the fact that it's all about the
ingredients
there's nothing fancy it's
straightforward but for me
it's so delicious cilantro
over the eggs now i'm going to place
those eggs okay
into the oven literally for about two
minutes
in they go take out my beautiful
bowl turn the heat up and what i want to
show you now is
a little bit of magic they waste nothing
here in oaxaca
tortilla chips in
okay lightly season them again
salt and pepper i've got this beautiful
mole
and this is a tomato finished molle
okay i'll drizzle that molle over
i'm going to get that up to temperature
from there put a little teaspoon
of my pork fat down the sides
let's just start almost tossing these
chips in this amazing flavor
okay beautiful
i mean really beautiful now you can see
i'm just starting to coat
i've got the heat underneath the chips
are sort of nice and crispy
we've got that really nice beautiful
flavor
you don't want to drown these chips in
that mole
just keep it nice and coated from there
i'll take my avocado okay keep the
skin on and just go across and
crisscross down
each side and what happens now is that
you
actually start to do little dices
because then you just get the spoon you
drop those
chopped avocado bits in okay
i'll take my eggs out oh my god the
smell
that was useful now we're not finished
yet take some
cilantro and just
chop through there again
and then mix in
and then a true mexican cheese
queso fresco it's a sort of dry crumbly
salty cheese that is so tasty now look
look at those beautiful incredible
chips it looks delicious there right
hasn't got the eggs on there
okay and then just save a little touch
for the eggs at the end
beautiful now for the magical part
okay they're nice
and beautifully tossed
that smells amazing off of the gas lift
your eggs
and just very carefully slide that
on that chili beautiful
and then finally attach
a crema all the way around one little
teaspoon left of my wallet
and then i'm just going to come over and
drizzle that there through
and that has to be
a true oaxacan breakfast and because
it's so delicious
i'm now going to pay a full airfare
for ron sanchez to leave his american
home
in new orleans and get his ass over to
oaxaca
enjoy
come on get out
hola capitan
what are you doing dude good to hear
from you
livewise my friend how are you i'm well
i'm here in mexico
i'm in oaxaca you are
get out of town
i'm getting up to speed where we're
hacking cuisine
no dude i want to show you something
i've just spent 1472 dollars flying to
waco and back first class
to get up to speed with these babies
name
this dish what is that
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you for getting up so early to
answer the phone i love you
[Laughter]
follow me he didn't know what they were
get on that plane johnny and come to
oaxaca
quickly now if you enjoyed that recipe
please click the link below and if you
missed uncharted
then please watch it on catch up on
disney plus